just a really quick note everyone we
want to send a huge thank you to meet
dude for creating our new awesome logo
which is right here Chris John snake all
those guys that need to spend a lot of
time making this logo for us and it we
just make sure you go check out neat
dude stuff I know they literally have
stuff like every one of the internet
where is it's the coolest merch and some
really awesome designs so things again
in étude we really appreciate you guys
so much we get there welcome back with
that to the gen angeline podcast
everyone and we talked about the
Powerball phase all the other days
this episode is brought to you by
headspace it's not training your mind
for a healthier stress feed stress free
lifestyle with the take 10 program you
do it for free go to headspace calm
slash Jenna Julianne download the app
let's not how you like it
it's pretty great I'm trying myself or
the sponsor this week is blue apron get
fresh ingredients delivered right to
your door fresh as [ __ ] like really
really great ingredients all
specifically portioned out for you to
create meals that you'd like to create
we'll talk more about that later but
check it out your first two meals for
free at blue apron calm slash Jenna and
Julian yeah thank you sponsor Thank You
Nora sponsors Wow we have uh we've been
recording the podcast relatively late
the last couple of weeks and it's very
weird cuz normally we're like you know
Thursday rolls around Friday was around
we're on it but yeah couldn't do it this
weekend doing this we couldn't do it
luckily liked I was wiped from turning
the vacuum cleaner into Donald Trump and
sucking things up I was exhausting I
feel like as fun as much fun as we had
this week making the video it's really
took it out of us like I didn't realize
it till like the next day in the day
after like we're just know wiped it was
so much harder to like do it and shoot
it than I thought it was going to be
like to have the vacuum cleaner do what
you wanted in
so that on a camera was harder than I
anticipated yeah I would say I would say
it was deceptively difficult did the
shooting part you know because by the
time we got down you know sat down edit
it was like alright we did it you know
we can just edit this together now but
it was deceptively hard to shoot that
it's deceptively hard mostly though
because we kept having to remind each
other that like I can see your legs and
like your entire arm yeah like how do
you make a vacuum come to life oh it was
hard that that wasn't me but it was
worth it I think was worth it is worth
it yeah like with no green screen like
we could probably had a really easy time
with the green room but we didn't have
that so yeah eventually we should
probably invest in green screen that'd
be cool down the podcast though it would
be people you call them partners be like
in Paris or like in Egypt Rihanna or in
space yeah space maybe underwater we
could pod we could use it for podcasts
we can also use it for our streaming
press for now if you'd like us to be
underwater telling you guys who were on
the podcast you know when we first
started we were doing Ustream
we are currently streaming on Twitch
live every Monday now in case you're
interested
over at twitch.tv slash Jen and Julian I
know that a lot of you guys like
watching is live because that
interactions really fun the quick back
and forth so we are streaming every
single week now just just for your heads
up yeah sometimes more um we haven't
nailed down like an exact time but last
week we did it pretty late at night
because we are setting it up and getting
it all ready um but it won't be as late
like that all the time yeah yeah just
the mostly evenings might be Monday
daytime sometimes and then you know but
we're assuming there's gonna be little
it Camilla uh so we just went and got a
part where she is why not yeah it's uh
here's the thing we Powerball's big talk
right now two swells nine hundred
million almost a billion dollars yeah
million dollars and just just
free-for-all you guys - no no I'm
speaking for myself here but I feel like
Jenna probably agrees we bought it for
fun you know it's like fun thing it's
like an event you know it's everyone
talking around social media there's a
whole snapchat filter for the Powerball
it's fun you know you want to partake in
it we're not buying it to win the
lottery yeah I don't think you know any
you know level-headed person is going
out trying to win a lottery tonight
thinking you know this is good
investment they're just doing it you
know a lot of people play the lottery
that's their choice and everything but I
think it's just like one of those things
where you know it's it's just fun to
participate you know you know want to
just do it a couple bucks yeah you ever
watched like the shows that detail
people's lives who've won the lottery
and then are cursed by it but they have
like cheesy titles like the curse of the
wall like it ruins their life when they
wouldn't happen like their friends a
couple of them have gotten murdered in
the past like just I have actually adapt
yeah I mean the people just you know
it's terrifying what people do for money
and like it's scary to see people you
think you know and when a lot of money
gets introduced into a situation just
could the insane tactics people use to
to get their hands on it right scary I
mean I said to Jenna earlier I was like
I don't want any part of this lettering
like in any alternate universe where I
would win I would hate I don't want to
win that money like that is the type of
money that absolutely gives you more
problems in you and you never
anticipated having in your whole life
after taxes it's what like four hundred
five hundred million maybe four hundred
if you did like a lump sum or something
I don't not even that good five hundred
millions what state you're in I guess
I'm trying to [ __ ] win 900 million or
nothing there's a there has to be a law
of diminishing returns in terms of what
you win in how much it negatively
affects your life or positively
affection because I feel like you could
win a sum of money that made it show
like maybe you got out of credit card
debt yeah I think that's actually a
really interesting point like there is a
limit to where a man for everybody we're
like all right this this amount of money
would not ever destroy my life it would
significantly help my life but then this
amount of money would probably make it
that you know maybe my crazy uncle might
want to murder me
yeah there's a couple different like
layers to it also so you know the big
Powerball like the winner you know
should win will get announced hope you
all over everything everyone who ever
knew them in real life in person knows
they won now that comes with it but you
know on the smaller scale like so you
want like a fifty thousand dollar small
lottery somewhere you know whatever
that's the type of thing where you're
like okay I can take you know 40 grand
whatever and put it towards something
that could tangibly you know move my
life forward right now or do something
that would take away off my back did do
some positive just whatever it is is
tangible you know I mean like you have
the money and you're putting it on
something with the money that you can
win with Powerball it's like it's so
overwhelming and it's so like
astronomical that you are almost like
overwhelmed in every single sense of it
so overwhelming like not only are you
overwhelmed with how do I even start to
arrange and do things with this money
but you don't even know what nine
hundred million dollars is like nobody
knows what that is in a sense it's crazy
it's like it's it's way too much
responsibility without much mom has
responsible a lot responsibility and yes
you could never like go and you know
claim it in your name that's horrifying
like you would never want to go beyond
the news like yo won the [ __ ] lottery
but my mother talked to your name for me
when I was little and my mom was you
know I'd be like mom let's go play the
lottery she was like no I don't want to
she never wanted to and just like it's
really sad like people will she was like
Jenna people will come here and knock on
the door and ask you for money and tell
you sad stories all day every day and I
was like I don't want to use that oh
yeah
so then we never played the lottery yeah
I wanna hear such that sounds like
torture mom everyday I hear a new sad
story mm-hmm that got me that told me
like if you were to win people would
come begging well yeah it's so much
responsibility you know you need to take
some of if you win nine hundred million
dollars and you just spend it all on
like a yacht for yourself
but you need to take some of it and do
something good with it my god how this
level of social responsibility
that love kind of money yes yeah I got
more if you don't then you kind of dick
you end up paying more taxes than
anything's here in the negative like
remember dreams on Survivor he he
bargained for that truck and then he had
to turn like to sell the truck because
he couldn't pay the [ __ ] the tax it
taxes on it well that's what the people
know that's just one of the things that
people don't think about
yeah they win all this money and then
they they don't know what to do with it
because they don't like think about it
logically or no one's helping them think
about it like you know everyone's
everyone's trying to get a PC action I
mean it's just it's just imagine that
for a second like everyone every one of
your friends every person your family
everyone who you might call them
acquaintances that you enjoy as a person
like what suddenly I mean this is just
worst case scenario but you won the
lottery and suddenly nobody is acting
the way that they used to act and
there's nothing you can do about it
because you have that money now and
everyone knows it and you know all these
dungeons lived in a small town can you
imagine oh it's like it's just a bad
dream like nobody will treat you the
same everyone's trying to get the reward
on your coccyx Oh Derek
everybody's meals on Derek you won the
[ __ ] lottery you can buy this whole
Denny's feed everybody for free yeah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] Derek dude I uh
yeah I mean it's just it's a scary
thought honestly but you know if we
could win a little bit of money and like
buy a plot of land to fill with cats
that would be fantastic and dogs yeah I
mean if the cats come within like a
couple months like it's worth it because
it's tangible you see an end and then
and then you bought it and then it's
over it's not this amount of money is
gonna change your whole life for the
better end I or specifically and more
importantly the worse I would buy
another vacuum cleaner and leave it
somewhere else if you have three vacuums
you know you made it that's yeah I think
Abraham Lincoln said that well okay what
would be something if you won nine
hundred million dollars
take home after taxes if you took a lump
sum maybe like four hundred million
dollars what's the first thing that you
would buy
see that is something I need to sit down
for an entire day
well I should know you gotta figure out
okay so what's the question rephrase it
so I have more time to think what would
you buy with what's the first thing you
would buy with four hundred million
dollars mmm fed by house yeah I would
tell her buy two houses the house and I
buy be bicoastal right away I have a
house on each coast and have a house in
the middle we're on the East Coast
hmm it's good question it'd be like I'll
just buy one house maybe like a small
town like Martha's Vineyard or something
hmm like a little low he's coasts Wow
that's what that'll cost you well I've
not I have 900 million dollars did you
win the lottery is something I could buy
more than it could be Julian's been you
know I don't think you can buy about
this vineyard fair night heard men don't
think so well you'd only have 400
million I don't think you said nine
hundred you just said Nile but don't
trick me government no take him out
after taxes no you just said nine
hundred mill what do you buy what
Julian's vineyard I even then I was
forgetting I had it I don't think you
can buy Martha's Vineyard ollars so when
we look up like how much Martha's
vineyard's cost it's not for sale though
what's it on sale of Black Friday
Mother's main unit Walmart versus
Chevelle
you got a walnut I'd like one month is
Vineyard please what I'm just walking to
Martha's Vineyard you take your flag you
slip no I won the lottery
not really I go say [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here we got to move our pallet I
bought your whole house I bought
everything it wasn't for sale
hey [ __ ] you guys is Julian's Vinny and
Julian's can I get a large ices nice you
take a post-it note oh the sign this is
Montana's you respect Julian's today
he's vineyard I've actually never been
to Martha's Vineyard I really want to go
yeah beautiful I don't have seen it you
know what movie I've seen in that I
remember very specifically is um [ __ ]
now and forget in the movie uh stuck on
you what movie is that it's Matt Damon
and I mean when they're stuck to each
other the brothers is that was help
stuck on you I don't I'm [ __ ] in love
that movie dude oh that is like one of
my buddy made that stuck on you I think
it's called stuck on you where they see
Meryl Streep and [ __ ] god
Greg Kinnear Greg Kinnear yeah yeah
stuck I think it's called stuck on you
why don't you look up how much it would
cost you to buy Julian's thing oh it's
one of my favorite movies I just
remember that really all right Martha's
Vineyard should I see how much it cost
yeah Martha's Vineyard networth Martha's
Vineyard warning kidding
is it worth seeing Martha's Vineyard oh
okay all right network can i buy
Martha's Vineyard I'm on the list now
you are okay so average household income
come on I want to buy it I want it's not
for sale that's okay that's like be like
can i buy oh my god what so average
household net worth in Martha's Vineyard
is 900 K that's a lot yeah I told you
you can't just go and buy Martha's
Vineyard I have 900 billion dollars if I
had 900 billion dollars I would shoot uh
800 of it into space so no one could
touch it and then I would buy Martha's
Vineyard for the last billion and then
I'd be done if I had 900 trillion
dollars I would sell the Louisiana
Purchase Bacchus trance-like upselling
though like more expensive we did some
stuff yo yo pay me yeah yeah we Bourbon
Street now those are called Bourbon
Street no the Louisiana Purchase no I
know but in Louisiana what's a call New
Orleans firms are yeah yeah I know what
the Louisiana Purchase I'm saying like
we added Bourbon Street here's a couple
hundred eighty thousand dollars now
we're in the Louisiana Purchase I always
thought that was such a funny joke to
sell the Louisiana Purchase back but now
I like live in the partner yeah I guess
I'm selling myself
yeah oh just move yeah we can move that
way you just have to podcast like from a
different place though we'd have to move
all this phone that would suck I'm
dreading doing that by the way and let
me move houses I'm moving all this oh
yeah is it I mean this should it's not
[ __ ] cheap but you know it's not Oh
gives me a high it's [ __ ] fun why is
it expensive I don't know I don't know
it's so ridiculous Lou if you ever go to
a Guitar Center and you're like alright
everything in here should be relatively
cheers I
maybe like nice and shows psych go to
Amazon just a little pro tip don't bite
it Guitar Center yeah um I feel like if
I won four hundred million dollars take
home after taxes let's sleep Fox I feel
like for Tiger you do I would buy one
house and I would live in it because I
don't want to deal with all these other
houses I might buy like an investment
property yeah but I wouldn't want it to
be like my other house cuz I'm already I
might write for one house you know the
responsibility of owning a house is
there's so much you got to take into
consideration about owning a house the
upkeep in me and it's like the whole
bicoastal thing I was saying it's like
impossible to maintain that by yourself
but I wouldn't even buy like a crazy
house I would just buy house uh house
that you could realistically live in and
maintain everyday you know what I would
do with that money what I buy a house
and you advise DJ Khaled chef with the
oh chef you'd buy her shifty you'd buy
her own chef teah dude she's [ __ ] da
got an offer you can't refuse
[ __ ] DJ cap I mean um well yes I
would I would do it the rock did he
literally built his own gym and not like
a home gym like this thing is a [ __ ]
power yeah I would build that for myself
and that would be on my property I would
we would build a whole studio to podcast
in like all that kind of [ __ ] yeah
that's what I would do I mean I would
buy the house first and then the plot of
land with all that stuff and then I
would buy 47 treadmills to put around my
property okay so oh okay
so my first things out by like a very
realistic house and I would live in it
for real estate would state I think I'd
stay around here go for it cuz I don't
feel like moving right it right the
second but what I would do is I'll live
in like a regular house yeah I'd
probably just you know buy the house
that we're living in right now that'd be
nice then we wouldn't have to move that
would be no that then I would spend a
couple years a bunch of time we could
build like an awesome [ __ ] house
somewhere else and have like a bunker
underground so even when the zombies
come dude you like you go and you're
[ __ ] purple shell turn it's like a
bomb shelter like a nuke show there's ah
it's also like a wine
exactly so we can go in there we could
hang out and we could watch Bobby movies
and get hammered and it [ __ ] crates
of Gatorade and peanuts for survival yes
what show is that from I don't know
Parsa burg [ __ ] sorry um you would build
a gym
I bought the gym I would I would have
everything oh god I [ __ ] I would
build a doggy daycare I would build a
gym and I would pay someone to come work
out with me not a trainer just a workout
partner no I didn't mean that in a sense
like Carolina I don't I hope you would
do for free pay a parent know like I
didn't mean to say like I want to buy a
friend like no it's more like a trainer
is not really what I need I just need a
gym buddy and I haven't had that since
like college you know it's like hard to
have radio you like Nutella story what
Nick did it makes me laugh every time so
needs to work out in college and a
friend named Nick Nick if you're
watching I love you dude but basically
we there was two gyms at our school
there was a fitness center for all the
students then there was the athletics
gym and because I you know I played
soccer play baseball in freshman year
and I was friends with the football
coach I got to work out in the athletics
gem which was great because they had you
know platforms just a better facility
and so I would work down there and one
of the soccer players Nick well he was
my friend you know we have classes
together and we I think we lived on the
same floor one year and anyway would
work out together and he's just this
wild
he's his wild guy like he's so funny
he's like always like hyped up crazy
energy and we would work out together
and it would just do the funniest [ __ ]
like while we're walking around the gym
between sets and all the [ __ ] like he
would never be sitting still and one
time we're doing cable rows but like
standing cable rows was really awkward
like you take the cable and you back up
and you get knowing a bent position and
you're just doing these but it's like
you should be sitting on a bench like
this but you're just for standing that
is one of the bench and I finish my set
and he suddenly takes the cable and
walks like 15 yards back like pulling
the cable to its end and then just drops
on his butt and slides across the whole
waiver and I'm like
what are you doing right now it was the
fun it was like the funniest looking
thing I've seen like he's little dude
just just getting swung across a homer
and of course he was fine he didn't even
hurt himself because he athletic guys
I'm picturing someone like sliding
across the turnaround you're done with
your set and you're like hey did you
video that and you're looking like what
the hell man I remember because we were
like dating at that point and you were
talking about like Nick and you guys
were gonna work out what time you're
gonna work out and then one day you just
came home and you're like I can't work
out with Nick anymore it's enough why
not Julian he's like it's it's getting
really kind of distracting a little bit
yeah it's just physically whatever are
you doing like how could that be
distracting what are you talking about
especially when you only have like X
amount of time to get something done
yeah and then you know some of that time
is just spent sliding any but that's a
gym yeah I mean that it's it when you
work out you have a partner it's a lot
less stressful you have a lot less
anxiety but you know you can also reduce
stress and anxiety by using headspace
which is great because those types of
emotions can really just get in your
head and wreck your life but if you have
guided meditation through headspace that
is not a problem it's something that a
lot of people aren't familiar with is
meditation when it's guided meditation
so they help you through it you do it
right from your phone you know you plug
in your headphones anywhere anytime the
take ten challenges ten minutes of
guided meditation and it's really great
follows you around you can do it at work
you can do it like if you're at school
and you have ten minutes pass and
meditate for ten minutes you know you
can download the free app it's free app
guys and do the take ten challenge which
is 10 days of 10 minutes of meditation
each day and I see how you like it and
that's absolutely free and go to
headspace complex Jenna Julianne like I
said I've tried it and especially in
this day and age where literally we're
going from one screen to another yeah
it's very important to be able to just
kind of take yourself out for one second
and there's a lot of benefit
a lot of benefits I mean it's it's
thousands and thousands of years of you
know a tradition involves meditation and
thousands of years of research involves
researching meditation and it has
absolutely been proven that it does
reduce stress and it does help you I'm
not a mother thing so go to head
space.com slash Jenna Julianne to try
that out
headspace calm / to enjoy and when
you're done you'll probably be hungry
but you don't want to shop it we hate
shopping
I mean we we use instacart and we find
ways to just not go shopping because the
grocery store is just a hassle you know
but imagine if you didn't have to go to
the grocery store and you had
hand-picked ingredients for certain
meals like like awesome meals meals like
jerked baked tofu with collard greens
and smashed plantains that's something
Jenna would love mushroom cabbage
dumplings sauteed garlic I mean this is
the type of stuff like mouth-watering
meals they deliver this is blue apron by
the way they deliver the ingredients
exactly rationed for that meal to your
door
fresh like in a box with a cool pack so
it stays fresh and we've done it and
then literally some of the freshest
ingredients like remember how good that
was yes and we had a lot of fun because
you're making something that you would
never make for yourself you have all the
ingredients like exactly rashes like
Julian said you don't have to measure
any it takes out all the work yeah you
do do nothing except like have this very
romantic feeling of like oh I'm just
gonna cook this delicious thing for
myself right yeah yeah and it's great I
mean and if you think about it even
between take out and buying expensive
groceries you're spending a lot of money
blue apron makes it so that with when
you get you know when you're paying for
labor and you have these description
it's less than ten dollars a meal if you
think of it like that it's it's very
helpful you can get your first two meals
absolutely free on us just go to blue
apron comm slash Jenna Julianne and
you're on your way you get to try it out
try out their ingredients and see how
you like it it's it's amazing you know I
want to say it's like cooking for
dummies but it's not dummies it's like
everyone has the same problems
everyone's stressed about cooking and
[ __ ] like that so yeah it's really fun
chat does it like his room like when we
did it it was so we did it
just like a couple of meals in a box and
then you get to choose which one you
want to make first and I just
specifically remember those like there
were like green onions and I think there
was bok choy in ours and they both
tasted so good
I know but that's what I'm saying it's
like something you would never make for
yourself yeah I'll probably like never
yeah like these meals you wouldn't even
know where to start minding you're like
oh my god what did I just do this is
delicious
it's really fun that's right I liked it
a lot yeah guys uh check out our
sponsors makes the podcast free for you
guys so we appreciate our sponsors and
register to support them if I won that
money I would start a company called
Julian enterprises okay and this company
I'm ready is just me okay it's like
Julian all inclusive like this is Julian
as a company and I would sponsor
podcasts so people would have to say at
the beginning a podcast this this
podcast brought to you by Julian and I
would pay more than all the other
sponsors every podcast I'll pay more
than all the other sponsors so they'd
have to accept me and I would do it even
to the people that don't like me so like
welcome to our podcast our sponsor this
week's Julian it's like [ __ ] that guy
but hey that's what I'm doing my money
I'll get my name everywhere Julian
enterprises baby that is actually so
funny that's what I'll do or you would
buy like every commercial spot pick out
on networks for like a whole hour so
it's just all Julia what do you like the
dirtiest oh no I would sponsor a UFC
pay-per-view to so I could have my face
at the center of the Octagon like you're
fighting like ah you know doing the mock
phase really like this is like the other
bird's eye view of George st. Pierre
fighting [ __ ] Tony hundred yeah
that's what I do I would sponsor the
hell out of everything so Charlie yeah
what I want to think of like the trolli
a thing that you could do with like some
money um I would genetically engineer
online Chihuahua
yes okay I've always may have this
discussion do we talk about some
projects but like we were having this
discussion just in case anyone watching
the podcast wins the Powerball so then
you can have some ideas of what to do
this is for you the winner cuz I know
winners watching us right now so we've
had this conversation that if somewhat
so clearly you know breeding dogs has
taken centuries like thousands of years
its eugenics it's actually pretty
horrible but so they took two hours so
that when you're in breeding chihuahuas
you're making them you take the nicest
friendliest like littlest smallest
cutest ones and read them together until
you get the desired dog that you want it
takes very long time to consider them a
breed so we have always thought of like
reverse engineering chihuahuas because I
think that they would be the scariest
animal on planet earth so if you took
all the biggest angry like meanest
Chihuahuas and they're so many because
I'm making the big guy human bigger and
bigger and so then you had basically
something that would make a pitbull look
like a sweet right poodle but they were
also like fiercely loyal to what we just
imagine like an ox sized marbles like
the anger and the fury of that dog but
actually sized up so they have a little
guy complex but they're [ __ ] cute
yeah like that's a terrifying animal oh
we were talking about that day like if
miles was huge fun oh yeah
and equally is like yeah like it
instantly mad - the way that your
marbles just turns on a dime from
happiness like you really would kill
everyone in the choppy of the two dogs
heads on it then you would just actually
run into traffic like trying to eat a
car oh my god that is so funny oh and I
would want a minute we've talked about
this in a podcast but like miniaturized
giraffes or other other yeah also I
wanna an Iggy well basically I guess a
greyhound cuz they already are big but I
want it big enough to ride so I would
just ditch the boosted board now just
ride my Iggy everywhere
put a saddle on that bad boy go peachy
oh that's terrible but I'd be funny
right
hmm okay if I had 900 billion million
dollars I would demand
that someplace that has dolphins allows
me to hook up a harness to them so that
I could water-ski behind them like
dolphins as they pull me mm-hmm if I had
900 million dollars I would recreate the
Star Wars saga like how I want it I
would just recreate all the movies yeah
how would you want it I don't know yet
Julie on everything though mmm for sure
yeah if I had this is like the game you
play on your kid yes I had a ball
if I had 900 million dollars I would I
would buy the whole stock market I don't
think you could do that yeah yeah not
for 900 million million you do you know
why it's called the stock market
why mr. stock owns it I mean by mr.
stocks stock market Oh mm-hmm I really
just want to buy like a plot of land
like that girl on YouTube Oh super mice
girls no no uh-uh her channel is called
camel's Minh okay we're good friends
Oh animals everywhere and I like I'd
like messaged her a long time ago and I
was like you're living my dream life I
[ __ ] love you she's a come on visit
and I'm like okay I don't know when but
um she's like a younger girl she's maybe
like the same age as me I'm not high
percent sure but she literally just
bought a plant I like a plot of land in
Arizona yeah and has all of these
animals that she I think she is like a
vet or she wasn't veterinary school at
one point yeah yeah but she like she
knows what she's doing she's not an
idiot like I would be an idiot yeah I'd
be like I'll just love them yeah Jenna
doesn't really work that way but she
bought this giant plot of land and then
has like camels and dogs and like
rescues animals and then gets other
animals I don't [ __ ] know how that
process works but her life looks like a
dream to me yeah like you just live in
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere and you
know what I'm gonna spend my time doing
today making a giant Salt Lake for my
[ __ ] camera and I'm gonna go feed it
to them
yeah you know what I mean looking
amazing like all the videos of those
like really funny like goats or sheep
running around and jumping on someone's
couch that's her couch that's her that's
her less terrifying house and how
accurate is to like your heaven it is
it's like what you'd literally would
love that and you'll love it no but I
feel like you could buy like a big plot
of land moves like a shitty car house
you know hundred million dollars get it
a nice house like the most amount of
money actually and then that could be
your life Julia we could have chickens
no here's my chicken here's my idea for
a house I want chickens - can we get
chickens by the way i watch party has
conversation and it's legal in
California I want a chicken coop because
I want fresh [ __ ] eggs man your
landlord would like if he had chickens
Julie Watts chickens because he wants to
eat the eggs i watch it they're gonna be
so free range because I want more pets
so do the happiest chickens we're not
gonna eat them we're gonna eat their
eggs though we all teach the dogs how to
be around the church yes yeah marbles
especially not giant marbles though car
going back to your house that only have
to be worried yeah no he's a killer
going back to your house on the bottle
and can we just make it so like if your
house is like huge it's made up of like
15 mobile homes so I can just like
disassemble at any point and then you
can just like travel anywhere look you
just need like 15 people driver okay so
we're we're essentially building a
traveling circus
yeah oh no tell one-tenth list ten free
yeah and no one performs tenth in gluten
free and no performances and made in a
facility with no boobs actually Julianne
prizes has some performance he can bring
to the to the his name is Julian he's a
great performer he also has Julianne
there's also an improvement
oh okay can I have my face on the mobile
homes
can I have my crop circle like pick up
my cut in the shape of my face so from
the space you can see my face sure do
I just want my face and everything sure
okay that sounds great
do you want to know what my company's
logo is what it's my face oh my god okay
you should like um pay people to tattoo
your face on top of their face so then
your face no no no everybody doing
enterprises for that that will have to
get licensed hmm okay yeah in each state
to two different license different
process do the DMV for four days
straight and sleep there that's rough
it's rough it's rough work
no for real can we get chickens yeah no
we should absolutely we should
abso-fucking-lutely get chickens if we I
mean I feel like it's a long shot with
with our landlord but if he approves it
I want to [ __ ] make a chicken coop
and have them be in our yard no it's no
small task to get them because I want
them to be like my best little friends I
want them to be like you know [ __ ]
Watson to yo you know who was gonna [ __ ]
her wanna come over and hang out oh [ __ ]
oh yeah she Anna's Jana's chick and
she's all the animals she's animals no
she does the cool life too yeah I miss
them can you guys just like move here
Shannon Chris like I see it on I watch a
lot of weird [ __ ] but like you know
people that have chickens and like
really love their chickens they're like
they're they have such strong
personalities like they're like little
oh yeah no I for sure pickle I literally
have a pecking order pecking order I
would really like Tom you know that
they're like they'll figure out who the
weakest one is in the literally packet
to death pecking order they're [ __ ]
vicious yeah well I'm gonna eat their
[ __ ] eggs man and they better taste
really good in free-range let's feed
them all the Omega Man well in order for
the V free-range we have to let them
Walker on the background they're gonna
be free ranged in their [ __ ] coop
that's the free range make enjoy all the
birds that can fly
Oh like a Saturday night comes you hear
with blasting rock band and then a
chicken just flies out of our house no
can you imagine like that video of us
feel like we finally got our chickens
and then we're like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
fall away [ __ ] it's like it's like your
butterfly video except they're gonna be
chickens oh my god
chicken I got it cool no it'll be like
that time that I had that bird and I
accidentally let him fly away yeah um
well you know the thing about getting
chickens what we'll try to do that yeah
long story short if we want nine hundred
million dollars we're just gonna get
some chicken no we're not gonna get that
ring in any way I want to name them
yeah well absolutely I want them to be
my best friends that's good idea Thanks
you can either eggs I'm not going to I
just want to kiss them I want to hang
out because of them - leaving your kids
okay can we take them in the bath thank
you guys for watching a podcast we
really appreciate you and listening to
our ideas good I'm not gonna lie this is
one of the most fun ones I think
whatever I like sometimes just sitting
here is me turning out in derping out if
you guys like the dirt podcast let us
know also let us know what you would do
with that engine million dollars in the
comment section so we can tell you that
the I'll just basically send over a one
sheet of prices for Julian enterprises
once you win that money thank you to our
sponsors headspace go to headspace calm
slash John and Julie and start training
your mind for a stress-free life today
take the take ten challenge
ten minutes of guided meditation each
day you won't be disappointed also
thanks to blue apron go to blue apron
comm slash Jenna Julian for free to free
meals on on us freshest ingredients
delivered right to your door with
delicious meals you will not be
disappointed
we'll see you guys next week yeah Thank
You headspace thank you boy responses
show them love also just as always links
in the description for all the sponsors
in case you missed what we said and I
got a loud text so I'll see you guys
later
thank you point with 900 million dollars
you can get a
that's not fish Shh Oh said the girl
whose phone is literally never on silent
even in a movie there thanks for hanging
your dad or it sound like a fine plays
he said I'm just a text we will see you
guys next week thanks right now